hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice and pretty crazy game that was
played in 2018 European Club Cup
championship it's again between Magnus
Carlsen on board one with the white
pieces for his team vålerenga Club
versus German Grandmaster
twenty-year-old alexandra duchenko and
it's it's a very feisty game very
attacking game features a very crazy
computer line that I'm sure you're all
going to enjoy so Crossan won a very
nice game then he drew his previous game
against Travis Lavoie taschek and now he
faces yet another grandmaster so all in
all a very nice preparation for his
match against Fabiano Caruana without
further ado let's check out a nice raw
footage video we have from the beginning
of this match there we have it
I try to do all over the audio so
hopefully all will be well there is
constantly writing down don't share his
name you know the dates and everything
and now he will prepare to make his
first move sorry about that for some
reason the video lagged for a bit it's
interesting you'll see he fixes all of
the pieces and the pawns there have it
and then he starts fixing the pieces all
over again before making his first move
and now he goes before they're heard the
first move has been made now let's see
how the rest of the game went so d4 like
we've just seen in the video
like we said or all the footage and the
photos is by Nikki riga all of the links
to her social media are in the
description below so feel free to follow
her to check out some other content
Knight to f6 we have Knight to f3 and d5
and here is one of the few occasions
where we do not transpose into the
Queens gambit declined but rather after
d5 we have III the Col system c5 as e3
was played a now a c5 attacking
attacking the central pawn and now
Knight bTW - as the pawn is still on c2
hasn't been pushed to c4 you do you
can't really develop and c3 you have to
go 92 and only then prepare to push c4c
captures on d4 we have
person d4 and Knight to c6 now Bishop to
b5 by Carlson pinning the night and the
now comes Queen to b6 we have c4
attacking the center and also defending
the bishop D captors on c4 and a now a
four this is only moved seven and
already we have a position that was
never before seen over the board there
this position is not available in
database and okay a six as night there's
no real way to stop Knight captures on
c4 we have Knight captures on c4
attacking the Queen and Queen to c7 now
bunch of captures on sisa and c6 this
comes with check you have to capture
there's no other retreat Square for the
bishop Queen captures on c6 and now
Knight ct5 would an attack on the Queen
Queen to d5 and now white castles we
have Bishop to g4 and here there's
there's a really no better move to do
then than to capture this bishop so
Knight captures we have Knight captures
and now comes a five so a very nice move
preparing to meet rook to d8 with a rook
to a4 so the d4 pawn will be further
defended Knight back to f6 Bishop to g5
back Olson and now e6 preparing to
develop the dark square Bishop and
perhaps even castle as you know it's it
wouldn't be such a bad idea to Castle
Knight to e5 by Carlsen and now come to
Bishop to e7 and here we have Bishop
captures on f6 and here you have to
decide whether we want to capture with
the bishop or with the pawn if you play
Bishop captures then you will probably
face Queen to a4 check and after Queen
to b5 defending Queen captures pawn
captures rook you have to c1 and this is
perfectly playable for black black does
have a somewhat weakened pawn structure
on the Queen side but he does have a
bishop against tonight the game is on
both sides of the board so all in all
pretty good compensation but I think I
think the Jenko made a a correct
decision deciding not to play this
against Carson as going in turn an end
game like this against the world
champion doesn't matter how good you are
you will you
have a terrible time so he decides to go
for a different idea and not Bishop
captures but G captures on f6 forcing
things to happen nice to G for by
Carlson and now comes Rock to d8 rock to
d8
is a good move but also the it was
possible to bring the rook to d8 even by
castling and this perhaps would wouldn't
be that bad the King would be very safe
on the Queen side you can bring it to be
it even to eight and then you would have
the King set all to yourself to be able
to attack but okay he has a different
plan rook to d8 pressuring this pawn and
now Carson brings the rook to a four as
he did push a five to be able to do this
Queen to be five attacking the rook we
have b3 now the Queen defend the Queen
defense pawn pawn defends rook always
well on the Queen side and now f5
opening up this nice dark square Bishop
Carson retreats with the 1993 and now
comes f4 and okay Knight to c4 and here
comes Bishop to f6 Bishop to f6 is
perhaps a bit slow rook to g8
immediately could perhaps good perhaps
would be a better move after Luke to g8
immediately pressuring the g2 pawn and
after Knight to e5 Queen d5 already are
threatening checkmate and white would I
definitely feel the pressure here now
but okay black has a different plan we
have Bishop to f6 and the now comes nice
to be 6 by Carlsen as the d4 pawn was
attacked twice so now the rook is also
guarding the d4 pawn queen to f5 and the
now comes d5 by Carlsen a very nice mood
that threatens to open up files and
start an attack against the King that is
still in the center of the board and
this is what I find amazing about this
game that black manages to play her game
with its King is still being run e8 and
you know it's it's like it's like
watching an engine play not not being
afraid of anything just you know
cool-headed the cool-headed moves and
always well I don't mind my king being
on e8 we have F 3 bi don't chenko now
threatening to open up the G file and
here we have G
by carlson but here the norwegian
supercomputer says they had a different
idea so if you want it just for fun feel
free to pause the video here and try to
try to find the supercomputers idea in
this position you know don't overthink
it
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations you have just found a
move a supercomputer would play and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
instead of course g3 the Punk should
come all the way to g4 as you can see I
have a tweet prepared here bite RJ
Swenson here he says that supercomputer
says and now shows that Carson King we
had a huge advantage after the crazy g4
and later it was shown that it it is
even winning it's a crazy idea because
why would you open your own G file like
this because now rook to G eight pins
the pawn but now comes another crazy
move King to h1 this is how a
supercomputer plays chess
so rook captures rook captures Queen
captures and rook to G one attacking the
Queen now Queen to f4 and now rook the
g8 check King to e7 and now this
wonderful move d6 check so you had to
find the g4 you had to find King to h1
and now even this d6 move all all the
way before you even decided to play g4
this is really insane
because now if you capture with the work
Knight see it check folks the king and
the rook and if you play Queen captures
again you get nice to see it check for
king the queen and the king and now rook
has to capture and now you play Queen
captures here after King captures as it
is forced King rook captures on c8 and
you would have a look against a bishop
black would have me up two pawns but
with a slightly worse pawn structure
white would be able to push this
definitely for a win so yeah now it's
hard to say if cousin considered this I
haven't seen any interviews done with
the world champion after this game but
okay g3 instead of g4 you know you can't
expect anyone to play a super computer
line Bishop to e5 and then outcomes
worked the c-4 by Carlsen and h5 making
room for the rook on age six the rook
wants to come to h6 to be able to give
even more protection to d6 pawn but also
you you want to open up the H file as
well
rook to e1 by Carlsen and now comes a
rook to h6 as as mentioned and here
Carlson plays rook to h4 also here was
another moment where Carlsen could have
played a better move rook to e3 seems to
be seems to be a very nice move as it's
attacking the f3 pawn black cannot
really afford to give it up so I have to
look to f6 now comes d6 again a very
nice idea because now Bishop captures is
met with rook to d4 a double attack
against the bishop and after E 5 now the
rook from f6 is guarding the bishop now
even comes Knight to c4 with a triple
attack against this bishop with a double
attack against the pawn on e5 the pawn
is pinned you cannot capture and this
will be winning for white so after the
six black would have to capture with the
rook but now comes work to see it check
King moves and now Queen to c1 but this
is again a very hard to find all the way
from there because now you're
threatening Queen to c7 which would
elite the checkmate and if black plays
rook to d4 guarding the c7 square now
you get the rook captures on f3 Queen
captures and now comes Queen the c5
check you cannot walk with the rook
because again this will lead the
checkmate after Queen captures here so
after this check
you would have to block with the bishop
and then Queen captures rook guarding
the f2 pawn guarding the d1 square so no
checks are available here and white
would enjoy a better position here if
Queen captures on b3 black would even
lose the game because now rope to h8 and
there is no defense against Knight to c8
check capturing the bishop if you move
the bishop you get the Queen to d8 and
if you could play e5 then you get a very
nice move Knight to d5 check attacking
the king and the rook King moves now
comes
rook check on e8 King to f5 and now even
g4 h captures and now Knight to e3 and
it is over black has to either give up
the Queen or move the King and then
black is getting checkmated after rook
to h8 checkmate so a lot of very nice
ideas here now but okay after Luke to h6
rook to h4 was played by Carson he
didn't go for the
rook to e3 line push up the c3 and now
rook to f4 I move to a for attacking the
Queen but also forcing a draw here Queen
to h3 was played and now black is
threatening checkmate so you do have to
give up the exchange here but cousin
planned to this rook captures on f3
Bishop captures an e1 Queen captures
anyone and now h4 we have Queen to e4
going for this Queen to a4 check ideas
and here black has to accept it there's
really no other move to play if you play
something like D captures on e6 black
will even ignore you and simply play H
captures on g3 if he captures on f7 then
King to f8 and there's no way to
continue the attack Queen to b4 check
will be met with rook to d6 and now
again nothing to do here if you try
something like Knight to d7 check to
bring the Queen back and rook the g3 it
doesn't help you simply King took
captures on f7 and black is up a whole
rook
so after h4 cousin has to go for this
Queen to e4 idea going for a 4 but now
we have simply H captures and g3 and now
there's simply no time the threat is of
course the capture here so Carlson has
to go for a nice check Quint way for
check King to a faith and Queen to b4
check here simply moves were repeated
and after King 288 the players agreed to
a draw so an excellent well we might
even say victory for for a 20 year old
German Grandmaster alexandra duchenko as
he held the world champion to a draw
while you know starting and ending the
game with his King on the 8th so very
impressive and it doesn't help you if
you try to escape here even though
captures does not win your Queen
because rook simply pins rook so you
cannot capture the Queen now and now
after Queen to e7 attacking the rook on
d8
our rope to f8 d6 now white will try to
promote this pawn but it doesn't matter
Queen a5 we have d7 and now Queen to be
one check and now black was simply
reposition his Queen to guard the Queen
Square acting f1 Queen check here and if
King tries to escape then black will be
able to position this Queen Queen d1
check King moves and now even King to G
seven is possible as the rook and the
Queen are guarding the queening square
so after something like captures of
course you cannot capture as the pony
spins captures and captures white is up
a piece and preparing to go ahead to
promote respond to a queen but now white
will not be able to escape perpetual
check here so a both players precisely
calculated this after Queen two before
checking two eight was played and a nice
draw was agreed upon so now that's the
game from round four of the 2018
European Club Cup I do hope you enjoyed
it a very very feisty game with some
very nice super computer lines also some
news
ding Liron in in the same round has
defeated Peter Svidler and with this
victory Bingley rain is now on his 91st
game without a defeat his last game the
last game King Lear and lost was
somewhere either in November or perhaps
September last year but I think it's in
September last year in 2017 against
onigiri so definitely an impressive feat
biding clearin here I also have a couple
of nice photos also by Nikki Riga there
you have a nice photo of Dingley rain
from this round with the with the white
pieces and here you have a nice photo of
Peter Svidler so if you would like me to
show that game as well you know just
write in the comments here I'd like to
see that game as well so I would like to
thank and be Mitchell Thomas I Loki
Christopher Mayor Carl Martin and Evelyn
loci for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos here thank you for watching and
I'll see you soon perhaps with the
dingus River game if you if you'll be
interested in seeing it or perhaps with
with game 15 of the Fisher versus
Spassky series also today calls and
faces shot here mamedyarov so perhaps we
will see some some more nice nice
clashes at the top thank you all and
I'll see you soon